[Music]
all right let's go out to Fort Collins
Colorado and talk to Brian what's up
Brian hey Dr deloney glad to be talking
with you glad to talk to you man what's
up uh okay 17-year-old
daughter uh graduating in May she has
been dating her boyfriend for a year and
a half he's also 17 he's also graduating
in may they want to get married oh boy
next August they'll be
18 by then they are both planning to go
to college different schools same
area and um my wife can have a lot of
challenges as you might imagine around
this on your behalf I do too so got it
yeah yeah thanks um one one of the many
questions we have is uh how much we
ought to be paying for an actual wedding
service ceremony next
summer I have I have an immediate
response to that and before I give it I
want to talk through like how have your
conversations been up until
now like how is this Con how is this
this conversation addressed why do they
want to get married so young what are
they so what's the hurry like walk me
through that yeah right um conversations
have been plentiful okay I think they've
been
most everything's on the table okay um
honesty around this is a
struggle uh I am scared yeah just shared
that with both of them the other night I
said I'm not angry I'm scared and that's
what you're seeing yeah uh for your
future because our our goal is for them
to be successful there you go if they're
going to get married and we think um
there's maybe a better time in life to
get to start with better odds if I will
sure uh yeah so the conversations have
have been good it's been back and forth
it's starting to feel a little bit like
it's a compromise or
negotiation with the timeline um and
money's coming up as you might imagine
they they don't have
any and they're not going to have any
being in school full-time
right
um man
[Music]
um I I don't need to run through the the
data with you you know statistically
this is going to be a tough one yes um I
think right now there's there's kind of
a two-prong approach number one is the
one you're taking which I absolutely
think is right you're meeting with both
of them both of them right and um saying
hey we're just worried about you by the
way before I keep going what does his
parents have to say about
this uh schools a priority uh for sure
and seemingly less bothered by the
timeline
okay um as long as the plan for
education and you know succeeding there
continue uh I think we have different
outlooks on overall financial
support uh for them um and those have
been separated into here you know what's
School financial support and what is
you're deciding to get married at 18
financial support look like like a
living right surviving have they made a
budget have you sat down with them to
make a budget yet y yep yeah working on
it now and also um handing our daughter
some expectations starting in January so
while she remains at home while she
adults and moves toward that she feels
what it's like to pay more of her share
to start paying her car insurance in
monthly installments some of that kind
of thing that's been a point of
contention but it's what we've done with
our other kids we've just had to
accelerate this a bit because she's
wanting to get married at 18 right our
other two two older ones didn't do that
that early we had a different timeline
so we're having to adjust those things
as parents which is got to tell you it's
been tricky this is some of the hardest
parenting we've done yeah I mean it
sounds like you're navigating it as well
as you can I think a gift to them so
let's take marriage off the table let's
take something statis ically improbable
with a high likelihood you get hurt
potentially forever in a small sliver of
success let's say your 17-year-old comes
to you and says I'm a worldclass athlete
and I'm going to the NFL directly from
high school and I know there's some laws
and rules about that but let's just
pretend they could do that not laws but
there's some regulations and NFL
guidelines and things but let's say they
could just do
that you would be failing your kid if
you didn't say
okay the wait room just got real real
serious like like uh we've been taking
it easy on you because you're going to
have to get real strong to head out on
that field the workouts are going to get
heavy the responsibilities are GNA right
so I think it's important to look at
this as like okay if this is happening
we're going to prepare you in the best
way possible and part of that is letting
the 17-year-old know if you're going to
make adult decisions it's going to come
with adult um responsibilities and those
responsibilities have consequences to
them
so I would be failing you as your dad if
I didn't let you have some a taste of
that some practice of that before you
make this big decision here and by the
way
um is she's already thinking about being
18 she's still 17 she still Liv in your
house right right six more months yes
how how many six more months before 18
yep golly can I tell you I've I this is
not the right answer but I have a real
thing in my gut right now
that well I think this would be not
probably wise
parenting you're you're hearing me go
through this in real time okay and I've
got several competing things in my mind
I'm just going to speak them out loud is
that okay please thank you thing number
one is if you got six
months part of me would want to go
scorched
Earth you can't have contact with this
person I'm cutting off your phone like
you still live at my house and if you
want to leave after 6 months not light's
out and I know the Hipster cool thing to
do would be like well you just got to
accept it so let's just ride this out
and I part of me says No you're 17
you're my child and I see the semi
coming down the road at you and I'm
going to shove you out of the way with
two hands and you may even break your
arm when you fall but I'm going to
protect you from that
car so Parton me in my gut says go
scorched Earth and then the other part
of me knows after working with young
people for 20 years that you have a
strong possibility you're going to lose
your kid doing that mhm right um and so
I I so I'm I'm thinking of this out loud
in real time and I want people to have a
picture of what it what it looks like to
think about something in real time so
I'm going to say this thing that my gut
says to do but probably is not the right
thing the second thing I think is is
right you slowly turning on the turning
up the weight of adulthood here's what
this looks like I think the question
you're going to have to ask yourself you
and your wife are going to have to ask
is the or what statement
CU if next August comes and you guys
have put some hoops that they think that
they'll go
through um because I've heard it said
when you get married then you lose
College I'm not paying for college
anymore you're grown up I'm not paying
for your apartment I'm not paying for
any of this stuff you're married now I
get that and you also know as well as I
do what happens when an 18-year-old just
gets leted out into the world their
opportunity their need to go make money
can turn into some really bad choices
very very
quickly um and so part of me
says I'm going to put hoop a I'm going
to put hoop B like as long as you're my
you got to work full-time cuz you think
marriage is going to be going on dates
and stuff it's a lot of work because
you'reall goingon to have to afford X Y
andz so when you get done for school
you're gon to have a full-time job and
you might be able to see him on the
weekends but that's kind of married life
too and so let's just get after it and
youall come up with a dollar amount you
come up with a support amount you come
up with grades amount things like
that but if I'm if I'm speaking honestly
and openly I
think
if they want to get married at 18 I have
to make a choice me and my wife have to
make a choice is is do we want to be a
part of these photographs or
not and I will probably choose to stand
by my kid side and give them the best
chance of
success but that doesn't mean I'm G to
throw $150,000
wedding yeah thank you yeah we really
agree with you I'm so glad that we're
chatting because several things you've
said are have been either intuition
we've already started talking and it is
that it's a dance right to to support
and love our kids and if I want them to
be successful of locking them out and
not joining them is is the wrong recipe
for me personally yeah I'll I'll be by
their side it's the wrong it's the it's
wrong across the board and I can't tell
you how I can't count I cannot count the
number of parents who their kid um who
came to me when I was working at the
University and sat down this kid's 18 to
25 years olds and said Mom I'm pregnant
mom I'm gay Mom I'm dropping out of
school mom I can't be a lawyer cuz I
flunked out and how many moms and dads
have come back and said I would do
anything to have my initial reaction
back and have it be anything other than
I love you and I'm here and so I think
your intuition is right I think it's
psychologically accurate I think it's
philosophically accurate I think it's
theologically for my my particular Bel I
know yours are but mine mine is
accurate I also think just sign up for a
oh this is so great as though they were
26 and they've graduated college and
they have a financial they have
Financial Security that's not wise
either because you're setting them up
for a fairy tale that's going to come to
a crashing halt
right yeah I I think that's right on um
doctor is is finding that balance of
real world expectations a little bit of
a I'm G to say a sting I don't even mean
it to sting but a reality check over the
next several months of what this looks
like and then after that it's it's
tuition help but then it's emotional
support right um I do it really is
because I I don't I by the way I didn't
budget the next three years for this
well doesn't pivot either yeah and and I
also
um I think now's a beautiful moment to
say to your future potential and now
let's be honest um when I was 17 I
signed a 100% track track scholarship at
a University at a state 100% % I um had
the season of my life and then I dropped
the Baton in first place and I ended up
losing the District track meet for our
team by one point for the first loss in
a decade I then didn't ever want to step
on a track again I met a girl at a
summer camp and moved states to pay to
go to college I ended up with a small
scholarship and join their track team a
little bit later but all I have to say
is who knows what happens in the life of
an 18-year-old the next you know year
from now
right but um it can sure feel heavy
right this second right um so I want to
I want to hold that a little bit Loosely
but also prepping for hey this is what
this is going to look like we didn't
plan for this we didn't prep for this
and so you're not going to get $150,000
we're not going to blow the top off here
and by the way this is my money you
don't have an entitled right to it
son-in-law my expectation for the man
who marries my daughter is that we meet
for breakfast once a week that's
happening and I think you begin to treat
him like the man he thinks he already
is if you're going to marry my daughter
you will meet with me once a week here's
book number one how to be a good and you
find a great book about being a man and
provision and expectation and being a
good partner I think you you set the
stage for
him and there is the daughter part and
there's the raising the daughter part
and she's my kid but I think there's a
looking across the table at him and
letting him feel the
expectation my father-in-law did that in
a we lived in different cities but he
did it in a unique way that I felt a
responsibility to take care of his
daughter and by the way she's smarter
than me she was making more money than
me at the time so that's not what I mean
by taking care of but I meant you better
be a person of fidelity and you better
show
up yeah I love that idea he asked um for
her hand
last week
okay um and I brought something like you
set up so you just affirmed my my gut on
that and that's something that I I think
he's going to say yes to I think he
would get
that and and the thing you didn't say
which really is important to me is it
begins creating a space for me to love
my new son there you go and I I wasn't
going to say it because I wanted you'd
have to back into it but this is going
to be for you too CU at some point your
kids you're I
mean the hardest thing in the world I
say this all the time the hardest thing
in the world is when you love another
adult and that adult is in your life and
they're making decisions that you
project out are not going to be good for
them whether it's our our elderly
parents the way they spend their money
or whether it's our our siblings not
saving money or doing something doing
you know messing with substance abuses
or 18-year old kids deciding hey we're
going to go do a really adult thing
without any understanding of what's
coming next
yeah but you making peace with it over
time I don't know it's you making peace
with it but I think it's maybe you
raising him up and he doesn't sound like
he has a dad that's doing that I love
the idea with you saying I'm not
prepared to give you my blessing but I'm
GNA and you sit down and you meet him
and and dude I would challenge you
to give him as direct eye contact as you
could possibly
muster and I don't mean this in a
pissing contest or like an old Texas
mail kind of thing I mean he needs to
understand the weight of what he is
taking on he is
asking to join with your
daughter and for him to become the most
important man in your life and you're
are not just going to open your hand to
that uh willy-nilly
right and so I think there's something
about saying I'm not prepared to give
you my blessing but you can earn
it and I think you're a good young man
but from this point forward and I put a
date on it June 1st
if you meet me for a book study you show
up and help me with X Y and Z you show
me that you know what a budget is um you
show me that you can honor my daughter
in XYZ when you present how y'all going
to manage College costs and without
taking a bunch of stupid student loans
out you can manage housing you can
manage these things then absolutely but
just because you love her and you're 17
that's not enough for my
blessing love that yeah I really love
that and then helps us uh wife and I
pivot it's really been about our
daughter as you might imagine and trying
to figure all that out but I think it's
a her and scenario it really is about
him now it's it's game on and and it you
know foundationally it's it's still
about what do we need to do to give them
the best chance for Success against
those odds that you mentioned which are
very searchable and findable by the way
divorce rights in America so it really
it really feels aligned with our value
you said um and I think I think people
are going to listen to this by the way
and I want to be real clear I had some
coaches in my life I've had some
mentors that
have challenged
me on an athletic field have challenged
me across a table have challenged me
nose to nose and it was never me verse
them it was them with me calling me to
something bigger than I even knew I was
entering into
and so I think you saying I'm not ready
to give you my blessing yet because just
cuz you like my daughter by the way
17-year-old you don't even have a clue
as to what love
is you bury a grandparent or a parent
you go through a pregnancy you go
through law now we're talking love but
at 17 you like my daughter a lot I get
that so you're not ready for my blessing
here's a road map to get it game on and
that is not you challenging him and and
sitting on the front porch with a
shotgun that's stupid but that is you
you eye to eye nose to nose chest to
chest calling him
in right and that's a totally different
ball
game and I think being very very clear
with your daughter here is the dollar
amount that we can afford we have not
prepped or planned for this and we don't
have period here is what your next six
months will look like being a
17-year-old in our home with the
intention of swan diving into adulthood
here you go if you don't meet this I'll
walk with you to the courthouse I'll
walk with you down the aisle but my
dollars and cents are not going to
participate in
this thank you for that and so we're
about to hand her in writing because she
requested that so that was smart you
know the money part yep and what that
allows the six or eight months allows is
a chance for that to be a learning but
also a a reconsideration of choices if
she and he want to reconsider timelines
yeah and tell them we're done we're done
with that fight you know if that's it
that's it but here's here's how we're
going to show up and we love you and and
so may maybe there's some influence with
that also also I wouldn't be opposed to
saying and you wait till 21 and call and
yall walk youall have your diplomas in
hand here's the number I'm going to put
on the table for your
wedding and by the way if that's sways
them if that sways them that tells you
how they're they their maturity level
right yeah yeah we we've wondered about
that a little bit and you know carrot
stick mentality and it feels like really
close to manipulation here's the beauty
want to manipulate a good outcome it's
your money do whatever you want to with
it yeah you don't owe anybody
anything period there's millions and
millions and millions and millions of
dads in your situation that would love
to help their 25-year-old their 35-year
old daughters getting married they have
no
money and so the fact that you have some
doesn't mean she's entitled to
it I don't think it's manipulation at
all I think it's very very
wise to say I will be able to I will Dad
because I live by a budget your mom and
I will be able to put $7,500 towards a
ceremony in August
period if you borrow a penny more on a
credit card you will lose access to all
$7,500 period I'm not going to
participate in you starting an already
very challenging relational Endeavor in
the whole financially I'm not I can't
support that I'll be there I'll stand by
you but I can't watch you start off in
the hole like that you can do whatever
you want and then say if you wait till
you're 21 and both of y'all have your
degrees I'll make it
50,000 and maybe she calls your bluff
dude you got to save some money over the
next four or five years
right yeah yeah you're you're a mind
reader too aren't you but but listen
statistically speaking they won't make
it through college
dating and if they do good for them good
for them
yeah but I don't want you I don't want
you to ever succeed um I don't want you
to ever lose lose sight of this is our
money
and never let her know like always let
her know I will be at any Courthouse you
go to get me I'll be wherever you are my
participation in that though is going to
vary based on what I believe is your
ability to pull this thing off
got it and those are two separate
things is that fair that's fair will you
call me and let me know how it
goes yeah we will certainly try I love I
I love in fact I've never thought of
this and I think I'm gonna I'm GNA try
to implement it he may tell me to go
pound Sam but I love the idea of
um somebody comes
to Mary you know let's say some guy
wants to marry my daughter and he asked
for my blessing I love the idea of
saying uh you and I are going to read
this book together first and we're going
to meet over breakfast or whatever and
if you live in another state then I'm
going to fly out there I'm going to meet
with you this is that important to me I
want you to feel how important my
daughter is and if I can't afford a
plane ticket at that time I'm going to
drive across the country and you and I
are going to sit in a cafe for a while
I'm going to ask you questions about
love and Fidelity and your pornography
use and and I'm going to ask you
questions about uh budgets and
perspective um uh education and
perspective work careers I'm going to
ask you the questions that probably
nobody asked you and there's not going
to be perfect answers to them but I want
you to know what I expect of myself and
what I'm going to expect of the person
who marries my child my child can marry
whoever she wants to I get anything
about that but if you want my blessing
that's on
me that's on me
blessings to you good man I'll be
thinking about you
guys hey quick
lesson stand by your kids especially
when it's hard stand by your
kids